president Trump looking to shake up the
Democrats ahead of their big primary in
New Hampshire Trump getting ready to
hold a rally in Manchester tonight
before the 2020 contenders faceoff in
the state tomorrow Trump supporters
lining up for hours to see the president
while Democrats are in a state of total
dysfunction they are still fighting over
the results in Iowa and now they're
going after each other
check out this back and forth between
sinkings sleepy Joe and mayor Pete he's
a good guy he's a great mayor but guess
what he was a mayor he's a good guy
but the idea passing a budget as mayor
of a town the size of Manchester and
managing 900 billion do you think these
guys this guy's not a Barack Obama well
he's right I'm not and neither is he
neither is any of us and this isn't 2008
this is 2020 Wow and while candidates
continue to tear each other apart top
liberals are warning that the field
doesn't have what it takes to be Trump
the problem here is the Democratic Party
the idea of a political party is to win
elections that's all it's about if you
don't do that you have done nothing it's
not to make a point it's not to start a
revolution it's not to win an argument
it is to win the election I have the
idea of the Democratic Party that I read
about now see on television and that is
a bunch of people on Twitter running
around causing trouble the other
depressing thing about this week was you
know at his best moment the Democrats
are they just look like the gang of
can't shoot straight or can't run
straight and if they can't get their act
together soon it's it's gonna be over
before it begins
Wow Greg it looks like despair has set
in on the Democratic Party and you know
what you can't argue with them Carville
and Maher are right I can't believe I
just said that well you know the thing
is you notice there's a strong sense of
sadness in Bill Maher's voice and I
could feel bad for that and I could feel
bad for all the smart cool kids like him
and Sam Harris but these people were
warned right
every day for months on this show we
were saying you're gonna be in for a
huge letdown if you don't start thinking
about the future and stop putting all
your eggs in the impeachment basket
unless you divorce yourself from that
emotional fantasy you're gonna end up
it's it's like a worse hangover than
tequila this tequila does it cost you
nothing worse than money on therapy
I can't drink yeah but I got to tell you
the only reason why they're sad as they
keep their filter is broken right why do
so many smart people and Bill Maher as
smart and Sam Harris is smart
they keep stepping on the same rake and
it's the same rake we keep saying don't
step on it to stepped on it with
obstruction you step on it with
collusion you step on it with Kavanagh
you stepping on we there and we keep
saying you got to change your filter the
big point that I find that that I think
the fact that you're sad is the selfish
commentary because the country is doing
really great oh that's a good plan
you're really really great but I feel
sad and and it's like almost like your
sadness your emotional pain caused by
trumps personality is more valuable than
a stronger safer country and it would
only I'd much rather be happier with a
less competent more warlike president
because you know that makes me feel good
so there's a light there's an underlying
selfishness behind these intellectuals
that makes me want to laugh and watch
them drown in their tears and and that's
a joke it's round in their tears one
analogy how does the rake taste we
warned you I don't know I think you guys
must know the taste of that dirt and the
rakes teeth because gee I think half the
country still wants this guy out of here
and I'm sitting chanter I'm just sitting
in a state New Hampshire where I saw
today was like plus 60% of the Democrats
in the state say they'd rather have the
state hit by a meteor than see Trump
reelected is that emotional so no is
that in a melona point oh wait a second
I thought a minute ago the Reagan
emotional
I say I think I think you guys I'm so
curious to see how you react to all this
because in fact the reality is that the
nominating process is always a messy
process and it's always like a roller
coaster and sometimes the roller coaster
goes off the tracks and sometimes you
think Jeb Bush is going to be the
nominee and then it's Donald Trump
and then Trump is on tape saying awful
things about grabbing women and you
think it's gone again and look how it
worked out for the Republicans you got a
Republican president so we don't know
where this is going but once there's a
nominee I think the dynamic shifts and
you stop talking about that dysfunction
you start talking about Democrats
coalescing behind a candidate and at
that point then you start to see why
Trump has never never hit 50 I too agree
with you on in a normal cycle but I
don't see the Democrats Dana coalescing
behind anybody in this field who they
nominate have you have you have you've
gone to a few diners and heard a similar
opinion well I would tell you that the
mood here definitely feels like one
there's some excitement especially the
Bernie Sanders rallies like those people
are in love they they follow him they
believe in him he doesn't talk down to
them it's not condescending he has
always been who he is now do I see the
entire Democratic Party getting behind
him to try to oust Donald Trump I have
to tell you today I find that very hard
to imagine but you know if he became the
nominee maybe maybe we would see
something different the other dynamic
that's happening here is that president
Trump's coming tonight is gonna have his
rally here in Manchester and the arena
well he'll be was the site of his last
rally before the election here in the
primary in New Hampshire where he ran
away with it and I think he has a
special affinity for New Hampshire
because that was the kind of the first
contest that said okay he could actually
win this thing he could be on on to the
White House and so he'll be coming back
tonight and that it will be packed
people have been staying up overnight
there's people come from different
states in order to be here so the he
whatever he's done here he has locked in
his support and I think that anyone who
was in depend
in 2016 that voted for president Trump
has probably switched their registration
to Republican to vote from this time and
he only lost this state by 0.4 percent
in 2016 and I think that they think that
they'll be able to win that in 2020 I
shouldn't say I think they think they
think they can I think they will yeah I
think they will - Katie do you agree I
didn't think that President Trump may
win New Hampshire but when going back to
the chaos and the Democratic Party I
want to say that I agree with Juan in
the sense that we do have a very long
way to go here but when it comes to
momentum momentum doesn't just apply to
individual candidates it applies to the
party as a whole when you have that the
Iowa caucus vote still being in disarray
they still can't figure out whether all
the data and information was in the vote
voting system there's now this cloud
over the entire primary process from the
beginning about whether the person who
may end up winning actually won it
fairly and that is certainly something
that the burning camp will be thinking
about when they go into this if he
doesn't get the nomination and whether
they are going to then support the
nominee against President Trump but the
Trump campaign has been on the ground
all over the place not just in New
Hampshire a vice president Mike Pence
has been in New Hampshire today with
Ivanka Trump at diners meeting and
shaking hands and Democrats have had a
very hard time catching up not just on
the ground but on issues and they're
running out of things to run against the
president on in New Hampshire he ran on
dealing with the opioid crisis and he
has delivered on that and I completely
agree with Dana that people will see
that issue see what he has done and
decide to change a registration of vote
for Greg when's the last time you were
at a diner
I actually frequent many diners but
that's weird are there anything are
there other places besides diners aren't
there restaurants no just honor just
diner just diners all over - I think we
need more man on the street interviews
Jesse yeah wait wait wait JC JC Creek
Chris Wallace and I and Chris's wife
went to the red arrow diner today and
they have plaques on the chairs where
like Al Gore Obama even mayor Pete's at
I'm saying we need a plaque for Jesse
Watters right in the snow you might have
to wait in line outside
let your i'll check the temperature and
I'll be right up all right